Do you have anyone who has to lock their
door at night because they're scared
because they get like hate mail? Dude,
she's such a self-victimizing loser.
It's so gross. This would be
>> the clip. Play the clip. Play the clip.
Dude, get out of my chat. Get out of my
Get out of my Discord. Get the [__] out
of here, man. Right.
>> Oh, shut the [__] up, you stupid Really?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, Jesus Christ.
>> [music]
>> You please just explain the situation.
Okay, so there is a clipping Discord
that I'm a part of, okay? It's been
there for a while. I if Substances in
it, um
couple people here are in it,
right? And we post Basically,
I will ask for links to stuff. Uh I will
suggest clips to people. I'll retweet
other people's clips, right? Yeah, we
talk about [__] We laugh. We have a
good time.
And basically, they're trying to post
like cut-up logs with absent any context
as if this is like an evil doxing
server. Destiny wants this to go and
flow into his greater narrative that I'm
running like a cabal that's been working
against him, that hates him, and wants
to undermine everything he's ever done.
Apparently, Dickers is fighting with
Stardust on Twitter. Hold on.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on.
So, wow, commentary channel that's okay
with flagging people for targeted
harassment and then a bit said,
"If Bad Empanada a doxxing server
creator criticizing him and actively
called for his audience to give him more
creators' doxx so he can publish it,
would you condemn people for flagging
him? Honest question."
And then right here, Bad Empanada
threatened to doxx me when I first ever
interacted with him by posting this
image below one of his below one of his
psychotic tweets.
This comparison y'all make between
Destiny to Bad Empanada will never
convince anyone. Oh, this person's
totally moronic.
He's asking if somebody who is a doxxer,
like a known doxxer who is rampantly
doxxing people, right? Which is Destiny.
Now, I don't know what that what you
think Bad Empanada does or doesn't do.
They're now threatening to dox multiple
people. They're menacing multiple people
with being doxxed. Like, come on, man.
Come on, man.
And by the way, it's not about threats.
It's about who he's doxxed as well,
right? Threatening to dox you, well,
that's one thing. That's really bad,
obviously.
But,
Destiny doxxed a bunch of people.
BadBunny has doxxed a bunch of people.
Okay.
You're missing the obvious subtext of my
post. BadBunny has doxxed and threatened
to dox creators. Nobody would criticize
reporting those videos.
Thickers, I hope you grow into a full
human being someday, is what BadBunny
says in return.
Argument? Any arguments? Do we have
arguments? Could we hear an argument? Is
there an argument?
Where's the argument? Just say you're
afraid to argue with Thickers. That's
all you got to say. Just say you're
afraid to argue with Thickers. Just
actually keep it to yourself. Actually
just laugh, right?
Oh, boy. Uh, thanks. I've got no hope
you'll ever improve. By the way, while
I've got you, how the do you bleed on
about misogyny online and then downplay
Destiny's treatment of women? No, it's a
it's a pattern of behavior, for sure. I
thought it was irresponsible.
Um, and again, when all that stuff
exploded, I I took a pretty firm stance
at like I thought it was, you know,
that's not something you do to a friend,
right? Um, and I think that's something
even he would have admit. Like, that's
not something that you do to a friend.
Um,
What about to your ex-wife or wife at
the time?
To be fair, when he was doing this, he
was also like totally gaslighting his
wife and being like, "No, me and Lauren
Southern aren't together in any way. No,
you're going crazy. Maybe you need
therapy. Hey, wife, maybe you need
therapy cuz you think I'm somebody else.
You think I'm this Lauren Southern
woman. You're you're insane. So, maybe
you should go to therapy." Also, while
sending her to other people without her
consent. And you guys want this guy to
be in charge of your political movement.
You're all lining up behind this guy.
You are worthless. You are
wretched.
But, the this whole situation is very
complex and stuff, you know?
Um,
but yeah, I mean, you know, it's it's
it's hard to I guess explain my stance
on this whole thing, I guess, if that
makes sense, you know?
It's so weird that and people like in
this space were trying to call me like a
sweeper for him when I I think I took a
pretty strong stance like against
him cheering those images, right? And I
think
What is this strong stance?
Is it a really strong stance to say it's
really wrong it's wrong to do that? Was
that a very strong stance?
Start us is that the strong stance you
took? Oh, that was wrong.
Oh, that was that was bad.
Very strong stance. Even he has admitted
that, you know, it was irresponsible to
talk to somebody he barely knew.
Um
but I also can acknowledge that he's a
victim as well of having all that stuff
leaked. I can also acknowledge that um
that, you know, again, most men in his
position are not very different from
him.
And um most men in his most men with
less
influence than he has are equally
boomers, you know, and boomers.
Most men with less influence than he has
are said also men share nudes all the
time and everybody does what he does and
also he's just the same as Do you see Do
you see how it's the same concerted
effort to degrade anything appearing to
be like a a principle, like being
morally good in any way? Oh, just
everybody's bad. Everybody's Everybody's
like a total piece of filth like
Destiny. Really? He's just honest about
what a piece of filth he is, so
shouldn't you be like Destiny and like
total filth, totally like worthless
filth?
No. No. Uh even if even if that were
possibly true,
no, we shouldn't just we shouldn't just
allow that. No, you're wrong. You're
You're wrong. You're wrong on multiple
levels. You're wrong in that premise,
but even if it were true, no, we
shouldn't all just aspire to be
scum.
That that's not That's not the way it
should be. Come on, man. Um I don't
believe when men like grandstand about
like sharing pictures and stuff, I don't
believe a single one of these dudes,
okay? Any of these content creators who
are like, "Oh, I'd never send to nudes
with my friends." Shut the [__] up. Like
I know I know for a fact that most men,
if they have received nudes from a girl,
they have shared it with at least one of
their guy friends. Okay? At least one of
their guy friends. It's not right. It's
not something men should mention doing.
I don't think it's something men should
do. But, do I think that this is
remotely not normal?
No, maybe and maybe again that's maybe
very pessimistic of me, but Wow. This is
what happens when you disconnect like
possible
total overall like sum total of harm.
This is what happens when you disconnect
it from like somebody's individual
actions. If you just If you try to say,
"Oh, well, you know what?
Technically, like yeah, Destiny doxes
people and it's bad.
Right? But, you guys won't disavow your
doxxers." It's like, "No, I totally
disavow anybody around me like doxxing
people."
Obviously. Trying to compare Oh, dude,
is anybody going to take debates on this
over the Nek Andro stuff? Cuz I didn't
get a stab at this, okay? I didn't get
in that conversation and you are just
wrong if you're talking about what Nek
Andros did is doxxing. You are a
loser. I'm sorry. You are wrong
categorically.
So, if anybody wants to actually debate
this, I'm perfectly happy to have a
discussion. Anybody on that side, you
want to You want to step in? You want to
have this argument? Let's go. Cuz it's
going to turn out only one way. You are
going to compare doxxing people because
you are having a manic crash or because
you share with all of your friends to a
bunch of random women
to trying to assert ascertain whether or
not one person is harassing a victim of
assault because it's the person because
they're related to the person who did
this assault.
Investigating that one question with no
malicious intent, no intent to harass is
the same as whatever Destiny's doing.
That's what you're trying to collapse
and you will look psychotic trying to
argue that.
Such such a disgusting disingenuous
thing to do. You are all hacks. You are
all rats who are desperately trying to
clog the holes in your sinking ship
because you know if you flee you anyway.
You would flee. Rats would normally flee
the sinking ship but they're trying to
keep that ship afloat because they know
they can't succeed anywhere else that
this is the only place that their
conduct will be accepted. So come on,
argue it. Anybody wants to argue it,
okay? Any of the Necandro stuff? Holy
By the way, I don't know if Nick's
Nick's arguing something about Chud. I I
don't know that stuff well enough to
argue the Chud stuff but anybody who's
trying to like collapse the Necandro
stuff to oh that's just doxing, you. Oh,
Stardust did a reply or something. Give
me a second.
It talks about this. No no downplaying.
I just don't trust men like you who
grandstand about this
before
It's not grandstanding.
It's literally
Dude.
I think all men So actually when you
pretend you're against that's just fake
virtue signaling. So I'm going to make
it so it seems like everybody actually.
How about you just say yeah, you're
right. This is really bad behavior and
I'm going to say agree with you and just
not try to paint everybody's for no
reason?
I I don't know.
Before Pixie brought a lawsuit, wasn't
your group making fun of her for Sugar
and Spice?
Oh, I see. There were people like no
that's not Dicker's group.
There were people in spicy chat who were
making fun of her and that's like that
is the kind of dark humor that happens.
What's up bro? How's it going?
What the [__] is with this like
like
cuz you can't prove that it's not
normal, right? Cuz I don't think there's
like any sort of studies on if men share
nudes,
right? Well, it's kind of like Well, I
think when I think when phones first
came out, I think there was a pretty big
culture of people like sharing stuff
like casually, probably not even to
group chats, more like
pulling your phone out and like being
like oh look or something. I think that
existed. I didn't hang out with groups.
I you know, I
grew up late enough that I was hanging
out with like woke people in college and
they thought that was was just wrong.
Mhm.
Like I get
Hanging out with wokies? Hell yeah, it's
awesome.
>> I was I hung out with smart people and
smart people tend to be wokies. What can
you do? That's epic. But I'm just saying
>> Um It's like yeah, people didn't want to
do that around me. I think Is my mic
okay by the way? Do I sound fine? Yeah,
it's fine.
Okay, okay. Uh
Yeah, I don't It's just like cuz you
can't disprove that, right? It's
literally just saying like
Cuz I was arguing with someone a while
ago and that the argument doesn't
matter, but it's like I made like a
common sense like oh, it's just common
sense. And he's like no, it's not like
you can't argue that. There's no you
can't prove that. There's no way to
prove that. You have to actually use
like something tangible that you can
point at or look at or touch or
whatever. And it's like yeah, why why
even make the argument that it's normal
to do even if it's normal to do. Like if
it was normal to do, would this argument
still work? Like oh, it's just normal to
>> Yes.
Yes, it's about what the argument is in
service of. Yes.
It's about
>> work for any other immoral action ever.
I don't understand why she thinks it
works here. And like I read this and
obviously I'm like I don't Yeah, if if
someone I don't think it's normal first
off. Um I hope it's not normal. I don't
know if there's a way to prove if it's
normal or not, but like regardless
Like why even try to argue it? I don't I
don't understand. It only serves to like
downplay what Destiny did. Um
And like her entire little speech is
kind of serves to do that as well cuz
she's like I understand that Pixie's a
victim and all these other people are
victims, but also Destiny's a victim.
And it's like
You've just like walked in on a guy a
girl and then he kicked the guy the in
the balls.
And then you think to yourself oh, the
the girl's obviously a victim here, but
isn't the guy also a victim in a way?
It's like well, come on. Like what the
[__] are we doing? Like sure,
technically he's a victim, but it's like
Like he he can't you can't distract from
him violating her consent 3 years ago to
his like you can't excuse that or
explain it cuz he did that before and
totally disconnected from his consent
being violated and the all this being
leaked years later, right? Like it's
Disgusting them together. I don't give a
[__] if he's a victim. It doesn't make
any sense to talk about it in regards to
Pixie. He was not a victim when he did
this to Pixie. He you can't farm victim
points and make it okay. It's totally
insane to argue this. Sorry, go ahead.
I don't know, man. It it it feels
And I'm sure the crazy part is I'm sure
DGG people feel the exact same way,
probably. But it just feels like insane
cuz I think to myself like
the obvious answer here
is like I don't care if people are fans
of Destiny. I don't care if people even
watch Destiny, but it's like the weird
dishonesty about what he's done is just
so bizarre and I don't understand what
it serves to do. It's particularly
egregious and disgusting from the people
who said I can't be around this person
or I'm like distancing from this person
because of what they did. And now you
come out and you're like, well, actually
technically like all men do this and
also like didn't you guys make fun of
Pixie? Did she start this really
distance? Cuz I tried to look into that.
I don't think she did.
>> I think she retweeted some Nick De Oreo.
She got blocked for it. She was on team
Nick De Oreo, right? But now now these
people see that like there's a group
who's calling them out on their and
they're like, oh my god, we got to close
ranks.
Close ranks around the
I've got I have to watch her initial
coverage.
I I think it's um I didn't I had I had a
decent amount of respect for Lonerbox.
Not that I watch his content or
anything, but I thought he had strong
character.
Um and I had like an amount of
respect for Hutch.
I kind of lost all that when he like cuz
he he moral frogged, I guess for lack of
a better term, pretty hard when the
Pixie [__] initially happened, but he
slowly like weaseled his way back in.
So after I saw that, I was kind of like,
don't know if I support this guy
anymore. But,
I had like sir I had an amount of
respect back then.
>> He was I think I think it's somewhat
similar,
but I think he's I can't I I've sort of
understand his mentality.
Um yeah, I should try to fix that before
it's too late.
Anyway, I don't think he like has gone
back to Destiny or something. I think
the issue is a lot of his fans are
Destiny
>> think he's gone back to Destiny. I think
he's he's moving towards that though or
moving towards like a complacency.
>> unfortunately for him, he's like sort of
his He had like a bad and people he he
is very upset or he is very annoyed at
this concept. I think he had his own fan
base. He had a very like a substantial
fan base of his own that was growing and
I think he pivoted at a time based on
evidence. I think he investigated
himself down this he like sort of
started clubbing a little bit more with
Destiny and I think he got started
having people in his audience who were
willing to link him stuff and I think he
just happened to get like very
Man, I think it's it's just kind of
rough seeing how it over time he gets
like a little bit more like leaning
towards
Israel and I think
there were people in his audience who
sort of moved away with that
and then Oh, I
>> up with like a lot of the overlap the
same audience overlapping and then
>> Sure. No, I I get what you're saying. I
don't think he's direct I don't think
he's I I don't I don't think it's going
to literally be like
I like Destiny again. But, I do think
it's going to be like a you're basically
just an orbiter again. And I think he's
at that stage where he's basically just
an orbiter again without like
you know, outright saying I'm an orbiter
or whatever.
>> It's the thing is that all these people
need to realize is like that community
is just thoroughly poisoned. That
community it is it is like a cult it
operates like a cult. You will never get
you'll never be allowed to be as cool as
Destiny in any way. You will never be
able to grow past Destiny in any way so
long as you're like attached there and
you have like a significant audience
overlap, it will always be in service of
Destiny, okay? The The thing I was
trying to say though, basically, is it
it
it's very disappointing to see Lonerbox,
Hutch, all of these people run with the
snark Discord narrative, because I want
to think that they're also with Lonerbox
as well. He him kind of like skitzing
out at My Waifu like not even like
making a video, I think.
Um
I don't know the specifics there
fully, but it's like I I don't Did she
do anything other than just like
disagree with the Israel thing and then
start making a video? And he like
completely just kind of like went a bit
crazy over that, it feels.
Well, I think he had problems with My
Waifu. Dude, I don't actually know
totally.
I don't know the full story.
>> I feel like there's something going on
there that I can't see, cuz how obsessed
he was
how obsessed he was with My Waifu and
like angry at her makes no sense to me.
It actually like it even given like I I
feel like I've talked to a lot of
different parties, and I feel like
everybody's told me what they think the
facts are, and I'm sitting here like
Dude, there has to be something else.
There There's something else going on
here. There's something
cuz to me I'm sitting here and this it
doesn't make any sense. Cuz he he he got
like so angry about her.
Running with the whole snark in general
though is just super disappointing,
because it it seems like
like it
I don't know like it feels obvious to
me, I should say. I don't know if it's
obvious to everyone, cuz obvious some
people
do not get the servers
and are genuinely convinced that there
was like some evil doxing [__] happening
there. But it's like it feels like to me
you should be able to come and look at
that and come away
understanding that it wasn't doxing and
that these people weren't like, you
know,
doing crazy insane [__]
I I and to see these people like run
with that,
it's like
you're
like I don't It just feels so lowly of
them, right?
Like why why run with that narrative?
That's obviously coming from DGG. That's
obviously coming from Dan and Destiny.
Did you see that tweet that Spider made
where he's like, "I'm not a DGGer." and
it's like you got the screenshots from
Dan.
Dan censored the screenshots and sent
them to you to post. What the [__] are
you talking about?
>> Spider's like 18. He's like
fundamentally functionally
not because he's actually but because
he's 18. Like he's just I talked to him
in the Discord before. I thought he was
chill. I thought he was like a cool guy
but he's like totally [__] [__]
>> he's just like
it people that young you could just
manipulate very easily.
And most people have like a constitution
a
like uh morality to them that prevent
them from doing that.
And
certain other people don't.
All you need to know.
Okay? Yeah. Um
Destiny's Do you know what the manifesto
is that Destiny's been saying he's
working on? Do you know what that is or
what's going to be in it? I mean I
assume it's going to be how I
mentally everybody around him into
like leaving him or Lauren me and Lauren
did or something like this. I think
that's the general narrative. Is it
about you or is it about like the
anti-fans?
>> why he got sued. It's about
Okay.
What is it about? It's about that. It's
about
the server of the Snark Left Discord.
He's trying he has to prove basically
and why anybody gave him this
opportunity to like take so long to do
this while totally looking the other way
while he was doxxing people is beyond me
because it didn't just lead to, you
know, one person being harassed or one
person having their information leaked
or like multiple failed doxx attempts
that leave them stressed all the time.
It is
it's
it's it's lots of people, okay? Lots of
people been harassed. But nobody held
him to the idea that he would prove that
me or Kweiman were involved in doxxing
and he has not done that. He's not even
come close and nobody's tried to hold
him to this. And they're cowards for not
doing it, right? But that is
fundamentally what he's leaning towards.
He's trying to He's desperately trying
to prove that me or Kweiman were
involved in some kind of doxxing because
he lost his mind. He is totally He has
no self-control and he started like
going after people, trying to find their
information, calling for openly on his
stream saying he would dox them, right?
And then he's publishing information
about people. So, when he when he puts
all of this When he puts all of this
out, now he needs to prove that there
was a reason he said that. And so he's
desperately trying to find something
that connects it because he really truly
believed it and I believe he's slowly
starting to realize that that connection
doesn't exist cuz it couldn't exist cuz
something we actually stand on. Do you
know what I mean? So, he's like crash
got more.
>> Yeah.
That's what I think the man of That's a
big supposed to be a big chunk of the
manifesto is proving that. I think
that's why he's saying the Discord
existed for 2 years even though that's
an obvious lie.
The most frustrating thing to me uh and
I've said this on like streams or
whatever, it's just like
the issue isn't even like they don't
actually have a moral issue here.
They're not looking at anything that's
going on
and saying, "I have an issue with this."
They're looking at it and they're
pointing and they're like, "Oh, look.
These guys, they're actually just as bad
as us." They're So, they're not even
like trying to deny doxxing. They're not
even trying to like say like, "No, we
don't dox. These guys dox. Like they're
the ones that are doing, you know, all
this shit."
They're not even doing that. It's just
like, "Oh, no, they're just hypocrites.
We're We're bad people. We do bad
things, but they also do bad things."
It's just like there's no I don't know.
That's just the most frustrating part.
There's just nothing for them to grab
onto other than like
What you guys are just as bad. It's like
I don't know. Just [clears throat]
It's really
I'm glad Listen, I was never a big
Destiny guy and I'm glad I can say that,
okay? I was never
I listened to the JonTron debate and I
laughed and that's it, okay, dude?
It's um it's like this concerted effort
to like Destiny is a bad person. He's
like a bad person or if you're not so
erudite, he's like flawed and he's like
damaged. Okay? But he's like a bad
person. And so they need to make
everybody else who doesn't like him a
bad person. That's like foundational.
That's how this group operates. They
don't have anything they stand for.
They're just like everybody's as bad as
Destiny deep down inside. That's like
broadly what they're trying to go for,
right?
And that's just not true. That's why I'm
like
This is another reason you call me gay
cuz I'm like we're better people. We're
more moral than these people. That's
actually something I'm trying to stand
on is like you should actually try. I
don't know if I'm like a virtue
ethicist, but I'm like on my way there
or something.
>> [laughter]
>> It was just funny. It was just funny,
okay?
>> It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's
but like I do think you should broadly
try to do like something good,
especially if you're involved in
politics. Like could you imagine being
involved in politics and your only
principle is do no harm?
Or sorry, not even do no harm, but
mitigate harm. That's like it.
You like anything you don't have
anything else?
Yeah, they just want to make everybody
look like total pieces of like them.
Yeah, I think listen, I think it's fine
to
to you know, make mistakes and do you
know,
every now and again. But like
I think the the the main thing for me is
how you respond to that. I don't think
everybody's going to be perfect, right?
Whether it's you, whether it's
Destiny, whether it's any of these
people. I think
you're probably going to say or do
um
just respond to it
in a way that's like graceful, in a way
that's not completely
uh or the best that you can. Just like
try to try to be good. You don't have to
be good, but as long as you're like
trying.
Uh look like
Unironically, uh look at people like
Pisco, right? It seems like Pisco like
has his goal in mind. He wants to, you
know, do certain things, and he's doing
certain things, and none of those things
require
doxing or rolling around in like
internet mud past like what he does like
I mean, okay, I say that he's
you know, obviously
sperging out on Twitter with randoms
using ChatGPT or whatever, but you get
what I mean. Like
None of what he wants to do online or
like soy pill even, right? Maybe it's
not the best example, but he wants to do
like political advocacy.
None of what political advocacy entails
is
you know, roll around in the on Twitter
with
and and call them
So, yeah, I I that's that's the main
thing. It's like you you
I don't even know if Destiny wants to do
political
at this point. When he's like doing
manifestos on J stalking queen men, it's
like, come on.
>> was just to onboard women that he could
to be honest with you.
I don't know if that's the sole reason.
I think he cares about it to an extent.
I like
he cares about it to an extent that it's
something he could be correct on.
I think Vaush soul read the guy that
like Destiny's politics are just about
being like the correct person. Like it's
not about standing on any principle.
It's just being most precisely correct
in any given instance.
And so, but I think he does that so that
he be, you know, famous and and the
debate bro guy. And then that's like I
think that sounds really stupid. He just
wanted women, man.
I I I really do. I don't want to get too
gross or whatever, but like I feel like
you don't even need that to
get
like
I've gotten a lot while being like a
complete and wrong in most cases even.
So. I think he also like he is he's good
at it. Like for for all Destiny's
faults, I won't say that he like sucked
at it. He was like good at at farming
these debates and winning them or at
least making it look like he won them,
right?
Like
That's it. You know what I mean? So, it
was like his best tactic. It was like
the best tactic. He made a bunch of
money doing it, too.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, sorry. I We got to open up the
clip. Okay, hold on. We got a quick
Stardust clip here. What's this What's
this awesome Stardust clip? But, I I
can't really comment on that. I do know
that um I mean I I feel like it's kind
of hypocritical to be um blaming him for
being part of a forum, right?
>> the [__] up, you stupid [__] Really?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, Jesus Christ.
What the [__]
Who is that? What did she do? I don't
even know who that is.
>> blaming him for being part of a forum,
right?
>> the [__] up, you stupid [__] Really?
So, Stardust, I guess, here is saying,
"Even though Destiny was on Kiwi Farms
and posting in threads that had other
people's doxes in them, that's what it
sounds like to me. I don't know if you
can blame him for that. Can you blame
him for those doxes?"
And this was the line that every Destiny
orbiter took when the Keffals manifesto
was coming out, right? This stupid
Okay, sorry.
I don't have a I don't have a fantastic
moral for [__] so I don't really have
anything to have finish that with.
Apparently, she's talking to Keffals
right now.
Blaming him for being part of a threat
that is engaged in so much harassment
that my mother's address was leaked and
they went after my family. How discourse
brained are you that this is actually
something that you would say? Holy
Uh so, I'm not trying to get you mad or
anything like that.
>> Okay, then actually be a person. Right.
I I've expressed So, just like a total
psychopath, right? Like a total
psychopath that has flipped on this
issue 180 perfectly in line with
Destiny. As Destiny has flipped with no
principle whatsoever, Stardust has also
flipped.
>> So, this is about Flamenco, not Destiny,
by the way. Oh, it's about Flamenco?
Okay, either way.
>> so remind of Flamenco got on stream and
threatened to send letters designed to
his mom because he thought he wasn't
making enough money online or some
stupid [__] like that. So, that's the
guy that started us defending there,
just to Just to be clear though, the the
principle still has flipped with Destiny
as Destiny's flipped on this. Well, I
guess she might not have had it
originally with Destiny. Wait, was this
before or after the manifesto? It's got
to be before, right? It's before the
manifesto came out, but this is the
position they were all defending up to
the manifesto. Because Destiny had been
posting in Kephal's Kiwi Farms thread
and she had been a
I don't know whether Destiny posted in
the Kiwi Farms thread, but
Destiny defended Flamenco as well.
There's a whole section on Flamenco in
the manifesto.
I'll send you all the stuff now.
>> One second, yeah, sure. Sure.
Real quick. Okay.
I've not posted the thread link in my
chat. I never made a post. I've never
made a post in that thread. Most of the
information Oh, he hasn't made a post in
that thread. Sorry, sorry, sorry. Why
did I think he did? Dude, he There's a
post somewhere where he's referencing
that thread, is there not?
I'm almost positive I've seen a post
where he's mentioning that thread.
But
on July 18th, she claimed that I posted
in Kiwi Farms.
>> wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. I'm almost positive in my in my
mind I remember a post that was made of
him basically
like on Kiwi Farms, might be in his own
thread, talking with the Kephal's thread
where he like asked something.
I'm almost positive that this exists. I
think so.
>> He asked He asked something in his chat
about the thread.
He posted the thread link in his chat.
He just says he didn't do it multiple
times. He says he did once.
I don't post thread link in my chat
multiple times, neither have I ever
encouraged my viewers to get involved.
I'm pretty sure he linked the thread
once. He was linking like some image in
the thread or something. Yeah, yeah.
>> Um
And she was mad because it included her
dead name, not because of a doxx
necessarily.
Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, you can argue
that's you know
revealing dead names really new PII
that's a the purpose of harassment. So,
this would be Play the clip. Play the
clip. Play the clip. You get out of my
chat. Get out of my Get out of my
Discord. Get the [__] out of here, man.
Did I get you mad or anything like that?
>> Okay, then actually be a person. Right.
I I've expressed to you that I don't
approve of doxing and I don't
>> He's in your chat. Yes, he's in my chat.
>> you don't approve of him being in Kiwi
Farms.
>> He knows that I don't approve of doxing,
but So, but you're okay with people who
engage in that in your community because
he's there right now.
I mean, I don't think people in my
community engage in that. Nobody in my
community is doxing
>> not part of your community? Is he not in
your chat just like you said?
>> He's a much bigger He has a much bigger
community than Did she call her
At the end of this I don't remember or
not. We had this platforming discussion
5 minutes ago. We had the platforming
discussion. He's in your chat. You're
not doing anything. You don't care. This
is just Unless Unless you have Unless
you have screenshots I'm willing to ban
him if you have screenshots of him
posting doxx, but He didn't post doxx.
He engaged in the thread. He engaged in
a group harassment campaign.
stupid that you can't see that this is
the issue. The issue is that he engaged
in a group. So, again, just because
people hate on me, right? And that And I
can say the same thing about when people
have been directed hate towards me, I
just because they've engaged in it
doesn't mean they're also responsible
for every single thing that happens as a
result of that hate.
He is He's part of the group that is
responsible directly.
He directly encouraged it. I've seen
this be said about me. I've seen Cozy's
stream where he uses memes that use
content from the thread. How is he not
culpable here?
What kind of content does he use from
the thread? Oh, shut the [__] up. You
want me to like pull up the Nazi site
and look over his memes? I mean, I I
don't The reason why I'm asking is
because I don't know. I haven't paid
attention.
>> You don't know.
I came here to talk about you and me,
not about him.
This is why I'm mad.
Because you have no morals. You have no
principles. You're willing to just stand
by people who engage in group harassment
a forum that multiple trans people have
killed themselves over.
>> coordinated group harassment of plenty
of other people.
>> Group harassment? Group harassment? Do
you have anyone who has to lock their
door at night because they're scared
because they get like hate mail directed
to their house because they're
associated with that? I've said that
Yes, I would like to say is like hearing
Destiny today is like hearing Destiny
today. Hearing Keffals rant like this.
This is literally what Destiny says.
Yeah.
This bit, dude.
They're calling him like Keffals 2.0
like 3 months in.
>> But yeah, it's it's crazy that But it's
crazy I've not I've not gone back and
actually watched this stuff since all
this has happened. Only in the last day
or two have I actually bothered to go
back and look at any of this. I saw this
clip earlier and I was just like, "No, I
cannot believe this nasty
I truly cannot."
Can't? I mean, let's be honest. Well,
it's like it this is like literally
>> case, right? No, but this is like next
level man. Like she this is like one of
her
defining moments online to be honest is
getting called a by Keffals because she
was, you know,
uh making a totally valid argument about
KF and responsibility.
I I understand um
that she's arguing like you should ban
Flamenco cuz he's engaging in the
threat. Uh was there like an explicit
defense of his threats like with the
letters to Xander Hall?
>> No, I'm not I'm not saying that No, no,
no, no. I'm
I'm not saying they defended that
action. I'm saying
>> No, no, no. I'm not I'm not Yeah, I'm
just wondering if there was that, but if
there's not, then sure. I'm not No, he's
I'm saying that their standard now makes
no sense because it it just it literally
just Imagine just let's transplant some
variables here, okay?
Uh let's let's replace Flamenco with
Nakandros, okay? Nakandros has sent
letters to
Knox's mom, okay? Or he he was joking
about sending letters to Knox's mom
threatening to whatever.
And
then uh uh
this exact same thing happens. What
would Stardust's perspective be on that
now? Obviously, it would be, "This This
guy's insane. He's part of a harassment
brigade. He's trying to
Destiny."
That's what That's what her perspective
would be now. And she says the same
Literally in that tweet, she's saying to
Dickers,
"Aren't you part of the group that
harasses man like the the this totally
contradicts that." Dude, was Dickers
even like a thing? Did he have an
account made with that name? Like did he
literally he's getting blamed for
something that he was not around for,
yeah.
>> Wasn't even around for, yep. By the way,
I've made it clear Ethan Klein, when
you're when CPS was called, I was
defending you, okay? I was like I was
literally like, "Oh dude, what are you
supposed to do? CPS is really bad."
Dude, she's such a self-victimizing
loser. It's so gross. Uh give me a
second. Who are the quickest people to
demean women in this broader community
for their sex activity or non-activity,
use their bodies to demean women for uh
whether they've had children or not?
Ooh. I I'd like Could these people just
name names to make it less confusing?
Like just name the names.
>> avoid that broadly. I have to really,
really, really, really hate them.
Because generally I find it quite
uncouth. And I found this all out to
laugh or used to.
I got I feel like that's like the red
pill people do. Like, "Oh, your womb's
drying up. You even have kids, bitch."
Like I don't think I've ever heard
anybody in this space say that. I'm
pretty sure I've never done that. If
someone's talking like like calling
other people like losers and they're
like, you know,
35, no family, like I'll point that out.
But I do that for men, too. It's not
about women, right? It's like Oh. Yeah,
yeah, there's like plenty of situations
where I'll make a comment like that, but
broadly I don't think I demean women for
their sex activity or non-activity, use
their bodies to demean women for whether
they've had children. I don't think I
broadly do that. Oh.
Use their bodies. I don't know what that
even means. Yeah, no idea.
Like talk their their body?
Cuz maybe I've done that.
>> I mean oh, like baby stream?
No. Well, yeah, I don't I don't know
what she means. If she means like
Yeah, I know. I Use their bodies against
them or something? Like she gets called
fat all the time, you call her hog dirt?
Like that, maybe? Oh, oh, wait. So okay,
so you literally you call cool people
fat because when you do it to women,
you're massaging your ego. Okay, that's
what it is.
>> I guess. I don't know. You're all the
same in my book until proven otherwise.
Prove the negative, guys. Prove you've
never shared with any woman online.
Dude. Okay.
Okay. You all made fun of and demeaned
women multiple women and leaked images
and shared them further. You're
disgusting. No. No.
>> Nope. No. No. Nope.
>> No. Explicitly opposite, actually.
Dude, I yeah, it's These people It's so
funny.
And you were you were saying this to
Stale last night and I noticed the same
thing that like
for somebody like Stale or somebody like
Erodite or somebody like Stardust,
literally they would rather like they
would rather be friends and close to a
two goes like, "You're really smart."
Then have somebody come along and go,
"You're making the dumbest argument
ever." And they're like a good person
otherwise. Like if you're rude to them,
that is the highest crime. That is the
highest sin in their opinion.
It's bizarre, right?
It's a bizarre I don't I don't get it.
Like I would much rather have a friend
who like is able to be a good person and
>> to even respect someone if they can't be
rude to me, frankly.
That's That's
I just I don't Yeah, I don't get it. But
Oh, hold on. Who leaked the nude?
And respond. And did Matt just continue
associating with said individual? Uh not
spread choice of not spread it further.
It wasn't spread further. It was not
spread further.
I have a quick question for you, man.
Yeah.
>> Um Have you or have you not done uh
Stardust hog rider memes?
Yeah. Don't you think that's like unfair
to do like a for a like a young woman as
herself? You don't think Don't you think
that's demeaning? I don't think it's
misogynistic to call women fat. In fact,
if you call women fat too.
I think she's uh average weight,
actually.
Thank you, Kenny. Um Did you see her in
the That That is what a Jamaican would
say, Kenny. That is what a Jamaican
would say. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Back to the islands, Kenny. Back to the
islands. Actually islands. Six months on
the islands for you, Kenny.
>> Well, well, well, okay for me. Okay.
Okay for me. You want to go there? You
want to go there? Have a track record of
abusing Indians, okay? Yeah, but she
should be defending me. She should be on
my team.
Okay, buddy. Okay, we I've not done the
rest of these Decker sweets. She should
be posting Queman is lying. Queman is
lying. That's what she should be saying
on Stardust Twitter right now. But no.
All right, I need to read these Decker
sweets. Okay, we need to go through
these. It's not something you should do
to a friend. You say he would admit he
did You say he would admit he did wrong.
He has argued he had implied consent.
He's argued explicitly the opposite, you
stupid [__] I'd love to probe the this
distrust of men, but I Sorry, I'm not
exactly the misogyny stuff. I'd love to
have I'd love to probe this distrust of
men, but I I have more faith in
Beckett's sense of shame
than to imagine he willingly showed your
nasty to anyone.
What the [__] [laughter]
That's a That is a That is a Ethan Ralph
quote used with poetic license. This is
an He's just
Okay, buddy. He's She's allowed that
comment with like relatively little
concern before, so he's just reusing it,
okay?
Yeah, why are there no quotation marks?
Typical deflection plus ad hominem.
You've proven my point. No answers to my
questions. Just You're ad hominem-ing
me. You shouldn't have an ad hominem.
You're ad hominem-ing me.
>> [laughter]
>> I counter base, actually.
Uh what?
I mean, the answer to the questions is
quite literally just I wasn't a part of
that group. I literally wasn't around
for that. I've no idea what Blitz is
talking about right now. Why is he
losing all of the drama? I'm sure he
just wasn't around for it. He just not
You know, he wasn't in the community,
right?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay, I'll put your nasty to
one side for now. On the topic of my
crowd spicy chat, can you tell me what
has changed in your positions now versus
during the Kephals versus Destiny drama?
I can't listen to this right now. I'm in
bed and I don't want to wake someone,
but I also don't
Don't know what that is.
Too poor for AirPods. Too poor for
AirPods. Get a job. Get a job.
Literally nobody cares. That's gross.
>> [laughter]
>> That's gross.
Shut up.
I didn't want to know that. Just say I'm
not Just don't respond, actually. Just
respond tomorrow.
>> You guys are disgusting.
Also, I'm sorry this is like code, but
you can actually totally listen to
things on your phone without waking
someone next to you.
Yeah, you could.
Again, listen to this right now, I'm in
bed. I don't want to wake someone, but I
also don't really care to engage with
you beyond this point. You've avoided
all my questions, so I'm going to
disregard yours. Can you give me a
single point I didn't engage with?
Actually, go on bed, man. Go on the bed.
Did anybody who pulls all like I
actually have
is uh
I hate it. Dude, the picture that
Destiny posted earlier today to J Stalk.
It's like, "Sorry, I couldn't reply. I
was I I just got out of the shower."
>> sex. I'm I'm busy having sex. I'm busy
having sex. Yeah.
I Honestly, like the picture
that Destiny posted earlier today to J
Stalk, it's like gross, but how do you
not know how everyone else is going to
Like you just made Hassan's week by
posting that. And you can't even
identify that.
It's so sad. It's actually like low-key
It's like you need It's time Put down
the phone 20 minutes.
Breathe.
Consider what your next response is. You
know? Yeah. It's wild, man. Oh, it is
but it is like Dude, I swear to God
there was a DGG thread that went up
where they're all like, "OH MY GOD, MY
MY GOAT HAS
Oh my god, he like he has Oh, he's so
awesome." All of them All of them.
Hundreds of people are like
>> I I wish I could do that.
Dude, it's so depress- It's so
It's just black-pilling, man. It's
gross. Yeah. It's pretty nasty.
You guys were a part of that, remember?
We didn't pull that one really,
actually. And uh
Actually, don't I actually play video
games and make YouTube videos? I
actually have two kids already.
>> And you're a dancer.
Professional. Yeah.
Well, well, I think we're done with Uh
finish finish Wait, finish this clip.
Finish this clip.
I came here to talk about you and me,
not about him.
This is why I'm mad.
>> J Stalk, try. Because you have no
morals. You have no principles. You're
willing to just stand by people who
engage in group harassment on a forum
that multiple trans people have called
themselves over. You coordinated group
harassment of plenty of other people.
Group harassment? Yes, you have. Do you
have anyone who has to [__] lock
their door at night because they're
scared because they get [__] like
hate mail directed to their house
because they're associated with you?
I've said that that's not right. But but
two but two wrongs don't two wrongs
don't make a right. in your community
who you interact with, who you call
friends because you're a [__] snake.
>> But I need I need screenshots of him
actually posting docs.
>> I'll get all of those He didn't post the
[__] docs. He engaged in group
harassment.
She is Yikers.
>> It's gold. It's gold. It's gold.
It's platinum. It's a platinum clip.
Really blame him for that? Can you
really blame him that you have to lock
your doors at night? Is that really his
fault? Just cuz he was like kind of
around these people a little bit? Come
on. He encouraged if he encouraged other
people by engaging in group Do you know
what group harassment is? You have more
than two brain cells? Jesus, Stardust.
>> I know I understand what group
harassment is. I've had people on Cozy
direct their entire followings to come
hate raid me. So I understand what that
is. But I
I still need to see like like more than
somebody just participating in being,
you know, harassed or something, right?
thread in the same thread on a site I
think she calls her What was that you
said? What was that What did she say
there? Are you
How is
She has to say more than just being
antagonistic towards somebody.
Wow. Oh, interesting.
[__] brain cells? Jesus, Stardust.
>> I understand what group harassment is.
I've had people on Cozy direct their
entire followings to come hate raid me.
So I understand what that is. But I
I still need to see like like more than
somebody just participating in being,
you know, harassed or something, right?
Wow.
More than just, you know, people being
when you're going through it. You know?
You know, it turns out And you might be
getting
And, you know, the whole world might be
against you right now, but, you know,
just because some people piling on the
forum that you that doesn't mean that
everyone there is guilty, you know? Just
because just because there's some like
guy who threatens to send letters to
people's homes and he's piling on to you
in a forum that's like doxing the [__]
out of you. It doesn't mean you get to
blame him for it, you know? He's
actually an okay guy.
I wish everybody had their opinions back
here, you know? Yeah, I actually I
actually quite like the half of his
manifesto. I think you know that was
actually quite quite a good a good
moment in Destiny's career to be honest.
Um so I so I do wish you know this was
still maintained.
Like I don't I don't even think it's
necessarily true that they share no
blame. It's just that they don't share
the blame, right? Like people want to
attach it as if they were doing the
Dude, maybe maybe you know, you want to
distance or not be
You know what I mean? Like at least at
least give like you know, some tepid
pushback or something.
But it's just
I don't know. It's
It's obvious that you can't just blame
them for everything.
It seems obvious to me.
Seems like it's also obvious that
everybody's only flipped on this now
because Destiny's flipped on this.
Actually, it's it's the one bad apple
argument, okay? One bad apple spoils the
batch.
Yeah, I saw I heard that like crying
about me uh
she's like it's so weird that he cozied
up with Beckett. It's so it's so weird
he goes on about it. The Dutch yourself
scared so I mean I'm sorry. Shouldn't
she be I think that's kind of weird.
No offense to Beckett, but shouldn't she
be angry at Beckett? Isn't that
Beckett's trail? Like I'm sorry.
>> I I cozied up to make How can I just I
was on streams saying I'm going to make
Beckett my best friend. I'm going to
make Beckett my best friend. I was
saying this it was a joke about the fact
that obviously I hate Star Dust and she
hates me and nothing would piss her off
more if I was like tied with Beckett. I
was joking about that. I think Beckett
whether it was to be
or not.
>> [laughter]
>> That's like your your short beta otaku
story, okay? I'm going to I'm going to
go find this person. I'm going to be
best friends with them as like a form of
revenge. Wouldn't it be really funny if
I'm friends with the future
>> [laughter]
>> I'm friends with the boyfriend of this
guy I really
It would. That would be funny. Is that
untrue?
It is funny. Yeah, it is funny. It's not
I'm not talking about the truth claims,
yeah. I'm I'm about like you as a human,
you know? Methodological as a human
being.
All right, what's what's wrong with
that, Kenny? What's wrong with that?
I just don't like making women feel
unsafe and you were really an unsafe
individual and you're like creeping into
her life, you know, like stalkerish.
Like you're like, "Oh, I can't speak to
her directly, so I'm going to go through
the boyfriend." So, I know, that's how I
see it.
I'm like a proud duster.
Proud duster? Proud duster.
Um
Look at it like this. I'm just done
talking about everything until the case
is over. So, there's always a reason to
do it. Either bad faith actors in the
stalker community will try to weaponize
everything or trying to virtue signal
like Willy Mac Ethan will try to
demonstrate their virtue to people.
I think this is um
during when he had his fight with Ethan
Klein must have been, right? Yeah.
Dude, it's like he's talking to
toddlers. He has to explain
everything.
Yeah.
One full year ago. Fast forward to today
and this guy's like,
"Actually,
the biggest evils in politics are Trump,
MAGA, and then Jace Dock."
I
What are you talking about, man? Like
how
how do you not see this is just like the
most mentally individual?
You know what I'm saying? But this guy
will never respond to anything any of
his critics say with little any
substance whatsoever. Just like Trump,
MAGA, Jace Dock, and all of the other
weirdos that have infected our politics
now. The only
Why? What?
>> Jace Dock has infected politics, right?
>> politics.
>> and talk about this to some DNC stuff or
something, bro. I don't know.
Think you sound really smart.
Dude, him and Chad Logic have Him and
Chad Logic with the started set of DMs,
okay?
What I wouldn't do to bird this bird
this
bird man.
What her account is snarking is legal.
But and it's hard to explain. I know
people who watch this show understand
the [__] that we've been dealing with
since all this stuff.
But it's hard to understand like
this is a group of 50 people
that have spent all day and night 24
hours a day unemployed
dedicated to
ruining mine and many other people you
know the people's lives.
But this is like a specifically like
yeah the clients. But the logs drop and
it's like 90% [__] fire bot [__] He
is going to try to find trans fire bot
and figure out what happened. How did
this start? How did all of this start?
How did it begin?
What's going on here?